Mi chiamo Maryna e credo nell'amore!
Ho dieci anni, sono caruccia e mi piace tanto
la riccissima Candy Candy.
A scuola ci vado sempre tutta aggiustata.
Ogni tanto peró a ricreazione mi sporco il grembiule, perché
a scuola mia, le pizzette, sono sempre estremamente
farcite.
Allora la bidella Gina me dice : " Bella non
te preoccupá, che tanto poi se lava!
La pizzetta in quanto tale sta carica de farciume,
devi solo sta attenta a mozzicá!"
Mi chiamo Maryna e credo nell'amore!
Ho sedici anni e a una festa ho conosciuto uno che é un incrocio tra Simone Le Bon
e l'operaio che ha fatto il controsoffitto a casa mia.
Io só piú alta de lui eh...
peró... me piace un sacco!
Mi chiamo Maryna e credo nell'amore!
Con Giorgio alla fine... ci siamo fidanzati!
Mamma mia quanto é bello!
Vabbé, io so meglio eh...
peró...
... non lo so...
quel suo carattere introverso, quel suo modo de fare...
Me piace!
Mi chiamo Maryna e credo nell'amore!
Mi ha chiesto di sposarlo!
A momenti casco dalla sedia!
Fin da piccola, vedevo quei film americani,
con quelle belle storie d'amore...
e mi emozionavo sempre, sono fatta cosí...
Me sento proprio Julia Roberts :
il mio abito bianco col velo,
le fedi con i nostri nomi,
il viaggio de nozze!
Che bello che é l'amore...
Mi chiamo Maryna e credo nell'amore!
Peró... la vita de coppia....
me la immaginavo un pó meglio insomma...
Cioè lui me vuole bene eh, per caritá,
peró é sempre più geloso...
Quando mi arriva un messaggio, mi strappa il telefono dalle mani per vedere chi é.
Per carità, se é geloso vuol dire che ci tiene,
e a me questo può solo far piacere...
... peró ...
... non lo so...
un pó troppo...
Mi chiamo Maryna e credo nell'amore!
L'altra sera ho fatto tardi a lavoro e alla fine sono tornata a casa alle nove.
Giorgio stava incazzato nero...
Non ci credeva che mi fossi trattenuta a lavoro, pensava che fossi stata con un altro.
Allora appena ho aperto la porta... BAM!
Mi ha tirato un ceffone dritto dritto in faccia...
e mi ha fatto male.
Peró é fatto cosí lui, é il carattere suo...
stava pure un pó nervoso...
e poi é stata anche un pó colpa mia, quindi...
alla fine mi ha chiesto scusa!
Mi ha portato un mazzo de rose grosso cosí e mi ha promesso che non lo rifaceva più.
Certo con quelle manone, ogni volta... só dolori!
Io comunque il lavoro l'ho lasciato...cosí... nun se dispiace.
Mi chiamo Maryna.
Mio marito mi mette le mani addosso.
Se me trucco troppo, un ceffone.
Se me vesto bene, un ceffone, anche se lo faccio per lui.
La mattina spero sempre che nun se sveglia storto...
perché se no só dolori...
Non me l'ero immaginato cosí.
Durante l'ennesima scenata, Giorgio m'ha preso a calci.
Mi ha buttato per terra...
e l'ultima cosa che mi ricordo
era che in mano aveva un coltello.
Il resto ve lo lascio immaginá...
Mi chiamo Maryna,
ho venticinque anni,
e li avrò per sempre...
perché sono MORTA.
Ora sto bene.
Non sono sola, no.
Sono tantissime quassù le ragazze che hanno fatto la mia stessa fine.
Siamo tantissime peró...
peró stiamo bene.
Perché qua non ce trattano mica come ce trattavano laggiù.
Mi chiamo Maryna e credo nell'amore.
Quello vero peró.
Quello che non ti fa star male.
Quello che non ti uccide.
Quello che non potrò provare mai più.
Io forse ho sbagliato a sognare Candy Candy e Julia Roberts.
Ma non ho sbagliato quel giorno ad andarmene via.
Non é colpa mia!
MI CHIAMO MARYNA E CREDO NELL' AMORE.